هذا واعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي اصابه 15
عسكريا في معارك الساعات ال 24 الاخيره في
قطاع غزه وقال مراسل الجزيره ان وحده
الانقاذ الجوي تواصل اجلاء جنود
اسرائيليين جرحى من معارك وسط قطاع
غزه هذا وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه دمر
اكثر من 700 منصه لاطلاق الصواريخ في قطاع
غزه منذ بدايه الحرب واضاف ان حركه حماس
تتعمد نصب منصات صواريخ في المدارس
والمساجد والمقابر والمنازل حسب قوله
مشيرا الى ان قواته تواصل العمل على تجريد
حماس من قدراتها القتاليه واحباط عمليات
اطلاق النار باتجاه
اسرائيل هذا وقال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
اف جالانت ان الاولويه في مهام الجيش
الاسرائيلي لتفكيك البنيه التحتيه لحركه
حماس والقضاء على قد ها القتاليه جاء ذلك
خلال زياره جالاند لوحده الكلاب البوليسيه
المسماه عوتش عكت والتي يتم تفعيلها في
اطار جهود الكشف عن الانفاق في قطاع
غزه تفعيل وحده الكلاب عوكس ينقذ الارواح
انتم في الواقع تجبون القدره على القتال
تحت الارض الى اماكن لم نقاتل فيها من قبل
نحن ندخل الى اماكن لم تعتقد حماس اننا
سنصل اليها قط ونتقدم اكثر فاكثر
وعملياتنا تتعاظم ونحن نقضي على جميع
الشبكات التي تبنيها حماس ونصل الى
الاماكن الاكثر حساسيه سنصل الى وضع نسحق
فيه منظمه حماس ونفك بنيتها التحتيه ونحرم
من قدرتها على القتال كاطار عسكري وقدرتها
على الحكم انها مهمه لا يوجد اكثر اهميه
منها